[Music]
we play a lot of games on the same and
eco Channel and the node channel if you
haven't checked up No youtube.com slash
node there you go I love designing games
that's probably why I'm so into D&D and
being a dungeon master because it's it's
so fun designing something that's
entertaining for others to get involved
we have a yearly tradition where we go
up to Big Bear and it's super exciting
because I'm designing a game from the
ground up to play up there it's based
off of Metal Gear Solid we tried in the
past on node where we have a Solid Snake
type character who is stuffing his way
through a map but it required a lot of
heavy role-playing where everyone had to
pretend like they couldn't hear someone
basically we'd have our character
sneaking by and people would have to be
willfully ignorant while playing to not
see our hero sneaking around the map I
want to create a really good stealth
game that doesn't require people to fake
it how do we do that how are we gonna
make a really fun nerf stealth game that
you can play with your friends doesn't
require a lot of equipment or supplies
how do we emulate some of that Metal
Gear Solid 5 well 10 people choose one
every round to randomly be the hero who
has to go in on a mission steal stuff
from inside of a house and exit and all
the other remaining players in that game
they will be the guards who are
protecting the house and to be a guard
will have nerf gun we're gonna give them
kind of like a point a point B path so
the walk between it as if they have a
routine so our hero can memorize that
routine and use it to sneak past them
the last stage here is in order for them
to not have to fake or pretend like they
can't see or hear this person walking in
the same room I'm going to deprive them
of their senses
we'll get your plugs will also use
blinds on them I can take these lab
goggles here and paint the sides here so
people literally have vision cones while
playing the game I think that will give
us an actual legit stealth game where no
one's role-playing Nolan's pretending I
think it's to be super fun let's start
testing
so Steve's gonna stop by and look at
some of our ventilation today let's go
on the roof let's look at your skylights
this age we might have to take all this
we might want to spray all of this
bright orange silver no no no silver
everything not this put some cardboard
here anything black in sunlight rots the
Sun just degrades it nor rots if we
spray it silver it'll last a long time
even this right here this cord whatever
this cord it's a drain cord that's gonna
go that's gonna spray it all silver the
guy did that seems like yeah I've been
doing this for 15 years well no this is
bullet because you you he would have
come he would have sprayed this silver
you want yeah you want everything silver
oh really
this one has that's ventilation so what
we'll do is we'll do what we got going
on right here see this I put a sheet
metal on this is sheet metal put it on
with that use these kind of self-tapping
screws with a rubber gasket and it's a
real this doesn't feel like it but feel
the thickness of this metal you feel
that oh yeah screwing into that would be
yeah oh and ever I'm old but I'm not
that old here what's great about lab
goggles is they're super cheap also they
have this kind of area here on the sides
that naturally falls into your
peripheral vision so I'm thinking I'm
gonna do that 21:9 that's why it's ultra
widescreen so this is where they will be
able to see and I'm just gonna paint the
rest of this black here I think that's
all we need to do put these on five
minutes I have to do a better job
painting Raddatz could be a little
sticky tell me when you can see it
see it so that's the edge of my field of
judgment now without the goggles so it's
probably like way back and that's my
field is you know so it does cut it in a
little things it from here to like here
a simple way to do it is do a stuff on
my face I stand up from Dino my harsh
yeah there we go this is harsh this is
harsh
alright here put this on sorry about
your face and then we'll get hearing
protectors and then we can just try
sneaking around where we had her hand
Burbank because we borrowed Sigma's
lenses they invited us to do a talk new
location for company called hot rod
cameras being sponsored by Sigma they
have asked us to speak on a presentation
just to kind of share our experiences
with their new cinema lens line the cool
chance to just mess around with all
their lenses see some of the new stuff
that they're releasing soon so kind of
give us an insight on what we're looking
for from some in the future be great to
get some Sigma photo lenses for the same
Anika channel this is hot rod cameras we
are a cameras or unlike any other in the
world this is our new Burbank location
it's almost 8,000 square feet all kinds
of fun toys for filmmakers and all
levels of this region thank you guys
very much for for playing around two
lenses originally out front it cuts what
the book would be circular yeah
anamorphic bokeh would look like so when
you're looking at the out-of-focus part
there's this something next is original
hey everybody my name is Sam and is my
good friend Carmichael say huh
we make youtube videos we've entered the
filmmaking world through different means
than I think a lot of other people
our first campus or not remember we
didn't have to deal with objects we were
dealing with like GL ones and like HB
X's and things like the things that were
like Oh Len this was kind of an
afterthought and I get away that's all
it's kind of change this here before I
go any further into it we got a cool
little channel trailer up show you guys
a little bit of the stuff we make
[Music]
you know see I think you could argue
that the artists moving into this area
and making it the arts district is
partially due to the fact that you
actually encouraged it and made it
possible yeah but but but it took off
all by itself believe me I would rather
it stopped because I'll tell you what
it's done I'll tell you what's happened
in the arts district what you got is
you've got you've got corporate you've
got corporate happening now these people
that are moving in here they're paying
an insane amount of money they have no
time to create to be an artist you have
to have the time to create you need
artists that are making noise
you need artists that are making videos
you need artists that are just making
paintings but it's got to be cheap
enough they've got to be able to make
that art and have other jobs too I mean
even I for the first few years had to go
to the produce market and I had to lift
lettuce on rutabagas and off trucks my
rent was one hundred and fifty dollars a
month see that's the difference but I
knew I could make that in a couple
nights worth of work unloading a truck
so I would work a couple days spend the
next five days making art nothing but
art then I'd work a couple days you've
got to be able to have that time to
actually create something and stand back
from it and go whoa that didn't work
there's so many people coming from both
Silicon Valley and New York and China to
Los Angeles because right now
right now it's pretty nice and so so
many people that are paying insane money
they're coming here and then they're
looking at buildings like this they're
going this is only you know I get caught
like I said I get calls every week
baking to get people over giving me cash
offers and I'm going no no you know so
what I say is the only way you can
really keep a good thriving our decision
is to have some civil unrest down here
have another riot
I don't want to use the word for a
peaceful riot yeah peaceful right
I don't quake but not at this building I
mean corridor digital and our channels
would not be what they are for this
building right Brandon Freddy yeah
that's that's my new soundtrack
[Music]
yeah Saturday I thought that was a woman
I'm going to attempt to sneak past you
take my wallet off this table without
you looking and then return and I'm just
gonna walk at a consistent speed back
and forth he choked me chill about it so
he's turning to the right
[Music]
hey did you see I did not but a
approached the reflection of the glass
door over there ah I sensed you starting
to turn that way so I was like oh yeah
I've never really liked your you dudes
also work really well because I couldn't
hear anything nothing I got there no
walking I hear nothing
so sneaking Sonia's hear it let's let's
let's swap you want to try it you you
want to try the same thing let's see
[Music]
Ren's straight atmosphere
all right so okay this was pretty
effective so the only thing not
effective is my paint job oh man this is
gonna be interesting
yeah I want to do that again like fun
like it's like surprisingly well so I
guess the next question is is this gonna
work when ten people are doing it we'll
have to a house we're so off to see this
weekend